Merci pour votre accueil de la vidéo de
François Fillon
Je vous avoue qu'elle est un peu sortie dans la précipitation
vu le contexte qu'il y avait autour de lui
Aujourd'hui nous allons parler du
programme pour les présidentielles
d'un autre candidat
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Son objectif est plutôt clair, engager la France dans une transition vers une société  plus douce
et plus égalitaire dans ses rapports sociaux.
Et pour lui il y a clairement une urgence
des urgences, même.
Démocratie
Pour Mélenchon, l'urgence démocratique c'est de rendre le pouvoir aux citoyens
Comment ? En convoquant une assemblée constituante
Qui exclura de ses membres les
parlementaires de la cinquième république
et qui aura pour but de rédiger la nouvelle
constitution
Celle de la 6e république
Qui sera ensuite validée par référendum
Ensuite l'idée est de réintégrer
l'intervention populaire
dans le quotidien de la démocratie
en rendant le vote obligatoire dès 16
ans, en tenant compte du vote blanc
comme un suffrage exprimé
ou en généralisant l'utilisation du référendum
Son objectif c'est de balayer l'oligarchie
politique d'aujourd'hui
c'est à dire quand le pouvoir appartient à un groupe minoritaire
et pour ça il propose, entre autre,
de rendre les corrompus inéligibles à vie
et de lutter contre les lobbies
Dans cette logique de société plus égalitaire,
il souhaite mettre fin au pillage
économique de la nation
et protéger l'intérêt général de l'oligarchie
Il va entre autre créer une mission parlementaire spéciale
pour faire le bilan de toutes les privatisations
et faveurs fiscales décidées depuis trois décennies
et rendre effectif le droit de réquisition
c'est à dire l'inverse de la privatisation
des entreprises d'intérêt
général par l'état
comme EDF par exemple
Concernant les salariés, il propose d'empêcher les licenciements économiques collectifs
quand l'entreprise va bien
il le fait en interdisant le versement
de dividendes
dans les entreprises qui ont recours au licenciement économique.
Il propose aussi une sixième semaine de
congés payés,
une application stricte des 35 heures dans le privé,
la retraite à 60 ans et une
augmentation du smic.
Selon lui, il faut travailler moins pour
travailler tous.
Concernant le patronat il envisage de fixer un salaire maximum autorisé
pour limiter l'écart de 1 à 20
entre le salaire le plus bas et le salaire le plus haut
Il veut interdire les stock-options ou d'autres avantage comme les parachutes dorés
Alors où trouver l'argent pour
financer tout ça ?
la première étape est de refuser le
chantage à la dette publique
en mettant en place un audit citoyen
pour en déterminer la part illégitime
et en préparer un réaménagement
négocié
La seconde c'est la mise en place d'une
véritable révolution fiscale
rendant l'impôt plus progressif
avec un barème à quatorze tranches contre 5 aujourd'hui
pour que chacun paie selon ses revenus
l'instauration d'un revenu maximum
autorisé
100% d'impôts au delà de 400 mille euros annuels
une réévaluation des niches fiscales
la refonte de l'impôt sur les sociétés pour rétablir l'égalité
entre pme et grands groupes
et le renforcement de l'ISF
Se battant contre l'inégalité, Mélenchon
se prononce contre toutes les  discriminations
de genre, de couleur, d'handicap, de tout.
Il souhaite abolir le patriarcat
en renforcant la loi et les moyens contre
les violences faites aux femmes
en renforcant le rôle d'éducation du
planning familial
en adoptant une loi de lutte contre le
sexisme
en abolissant la prostitution
et surtout en imposant l'égalité des
conditions entre hommes et femmes
Cependant, même s'il est pour la
procréation médicalement assistée
pour toutes les femmes, il refuse la GPA (gestation pour autrui)
Sur les questions de la laïcité, il
souhaite garantir la liberté de
conscience et de l'égalité de toutes
les options spirituelles devant la loi
tout en combattant tous les
communautarismes
et l'usage politique des religions.
Il propose d'ailleurs de refuser de
rencontrer les pays
qui imposeraient aux ministres femmes
des tenues contraires à la dignité républicaine.
Il propose aussi l'éradication pure et simple de la pauvreté
par des mesures instaurant la gratuité
de quantités d'eau,
de gaz, et d'électricité
indispensable à une vie digne, ou la
mise en place d'un plan
zéro sans abris pour apporter accompagnement
et logements d'urgence à ces derniers
On l'a dit, Mélenchon veut une transition vers une société plus douce,
et pour lui ça implique une transition écologique
il propose donc d'engager un plan de
relance de l'activité et de l'emploi
au service de la transition écologique
en injectant cent milliards d'euros
dans l'économie
pour nos investissements écologiquement et
socialement utiles
Il veut aussi une sortie complète du
nucléaire en impliquant les personnes
qui y travaillent dans les opérations de
démantèlement
Il vise aussi 100% d'énergies renouvelables d'ici à 2050
Globalement, l'idée qui persiste dans
son programme, c'est de faire évoluer
notre façon de consommer transformant notre pays en France zéro déchet,
combattant l'obsolescence programmée,
et soutenant les filières et les initiatives de gestion des déchets
Il souhaite aussi mettre en place une
agriculture paysanne
refusant les OGM et banissant les pesticides nuisibles
pour protéger nos écosystèmes
L'urgence démocratique, elle passe aussi selon Mélenchon par l'Europe
selon lui, elle est décomposée et elle attaque la démocratie, elle oppose entre eux
salariés des pays membres en refusant
toute harmonisation sociale et fiscale
Il est nécessaire pour la France de
reconquérir son indépendance
et cette Europe là, soit on la change, plan A,
soit on la quitte, plan B
Il veut aussi sortir de l'OTAN, pour sortir de l'influence américaine
et se recentrer sur notre rôle à
l'ONU
pour lui, notre pays est universaliste et doit se recentrer
sur sa coopération avec les pays émergents
et tout particulièrement l'Afrique.
Donc voilà, engager la France dans une transition vers une société plus douce
et plus égalitaire dans ses rapports sociaux
à travers plusieurs urgences :
démocratique, économique, sociale
écologique et diplomatique
c'est le fondement du programme
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et j'espère
qu'il est plus clair maintenant.
Je vous met dans la description les sources vers son programme complet pour que vous
puissiez aller plus loin par vous même et on se retrouve très vite pour le prochain candidat
Je vous invite également très fortement à
aller voir la chaîne de l'ami
Hugo Décrypte
qui est habitué au format de type 5 minutes pour décrypter un programme
c'est quelque chose qu'il fait pour tous
les candidats à la présidentielle
et qu'on traite forcément différemment, donc ça peut être très enrichissant pour vous
Il a aussi une série d'interviews augmentées qui
permettent d'aller plus loin
dans le programme des candidats
donc je vous invite à y aller, je vous met le lien de sa chaîne en description
J'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu, merci à tous les Tipeurs
qui soutiennent financièrement le projet
on se revoit bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
Love, peace